tout s'est passé si vite
qu'il y a eu une éruption solaire
[Musique]
au revoir les récoltes et la nourriture au revoir
tout
donc j'ai eu
peur
et si seul
et j'ai trouvé que
tu enlevais tes coudes de la table garde tes
coudes bien levés
tu es le prochain
[Musique]
toi  tu vois je développe quelque chose d'
intéressant
acte de foi géant
[musique]
maintenant si tu peux parler
dis moi quelque chose
sur toi les
robots doivent protéger
si le chien ne part pas avant que la tempête ne frappe
nous mourrons tous
dès que tu pourras marcher  nous partons
un deux un deux un
mais ça
tombe vers l'ouest sur les montagnes voudriez-vous
que je conduise
ne survirez pas
c'est du survirage relâchez votre pied juste
un cheveu
parfait
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que ça m'aime
venir  et voyez cela
accrochez-vous à quelque chose que
nous devrions être en sécurité une fois que nous serons dans les
montagnes, ces choses se produiront
comme un rayonnement UV de chaleur à 150 degrés
et des gens se
cachant dans l'ombre
pensez-vous que nous y arriverons
pas sans mon équipe
ce que nous faisons
nous  faire ensemble
[Musique]
je crois en toi ce
[M  usique]
vous